[Music]  [Music]  first of all I'm trying to play some  training games to get some confidence  and also to get some decent training  then it's also opening preparation which  frankly speaking takes most of our our  time and is going to be very important I  going to play on traditional opens I  have to study I don't know to be honest  now there's there's Peter Heine there's  Laura who was who's been there in the  team for a long time then there are few  surprises some some younger people as  well who are bringing some creativity  and energy to the group and it's a nice  script where we we enjoy ourselves  during the World Chess Championship  you'll find a sneak peek and exclusive  content only on play -